all right so thank you so much for doing
this I saw the film yesterday and it
just moved me to tears I thought it was
spectacular I think it's gonna move a
lot of people when they see it you know
Lady gaga I want to start with you
you've performed live on stage for
millions of people around the world this
is very much your first major leading
role in on a big screen so what's
something new you learned about
performing from playing this character
in this movie well thank you so much for
being with us today
I'm so happy to be here with all of
these incredible talented human beings
on this couch you know I learned
something from Bradley that I had never
learned before he's such an incredible
filmmaker he's also just an absolutely
sensational director and what he taught
me was is know your lines know the story
that you're telling but then when you
walk on set throw it out the window and
just be and just talk to me and and he
says it to Ally in the film he says all
you got to do is trust me oh yeah
and that was like how it was every day
on set just an extremely sacred space
that was both operated with a lot of
precision and also a lot of freedom and
love Bradley I feel like I could ask you
that same question you spent so much for
your career in front of a camera and
this one you're not only behind the
camera but you're performing live on a
stage in front of tons of people what's
something new you learned every
everything in this project was new yeah
I mean that that's the beauty of it you
want it you want to do things you know
the older I get the more I realize time
is the biggest currency and I just
wanted to keep learning and surrounding
myself with people that are better than
me so that I could grow so I guess it's
selfish in a way but but that's what
every moment of this experience has been
has really been that sitting in this
cows with all these people as an actor
and we haven't really spoken about the
acting part of it but you know the truth
is everybody here I can remember
complete moments being there watching
them and then making me a better actor
because they just are so real and
present and listening and that that's
all you pray for as an actor you know
and then to be able to have that at your
disposal as a storyteller you know the
editing room becomes just you know the
most fun place to be and let's talk
about that story this is a star is born
this is a classic story you know I think
of Roberts Rassi and I think of Judy
Garland what about this story convinced
you that this was going to be a
directorial debut I know Clint Eastwood
had a role in bringing it to you how
much did he influence you and and what
was it about the story that said you
know what this is it for me it was a
sequence of events I mean Clint Eastwood
has influenced me in ways before he ever
knew before I ever met him but it really
was I wanted to tell a love story I just
but the thing that kept me from doing it
was I never had a point of view of a
story and the only reason to do anything
to say anything is if you know what you
want to say and it really was it was it
was this it was I wanted to tell a love
story you know and a human story and the
story about relationships and trauma and
but I wanted to be cinematic so I'm one
of the characters to be something that
maybe one in their everyday lives they
don't experience
so music was a perfect vehicle for that
and then finding her was incredible can
I ask you a personal question
okay tell me something good do you write
songs or anything
I don't sing my own songs why I just
don't feel comfortable why wouldn't you
feel comfortable almost every single
person has told me they like the way I
sounded but that they didn't like the
way I look I think you're beautiful you
know Anthony I feel like you're very
much an actor whose star is on the rise
right now I've seen you in a bunch of
things and of course Hamilton this movie
very much speaks to sort of maintaining
your authenticity and ownership over who
you are as an artist as your as more
people are saying this is what you
should look like this is who you should
be is that something that you struggle
with personally in your career right now
and is that a struggle I've had people
tell me you need to speak differently
you need to grow your hair out due to
this you're not enough of that you know
you're not tall enough
you ain't short enough you know honestly
man like my family you know I think I'm
like grateful that I have a family that
reminds me of Who I am
and then like when you just have people
reminding you like like nothing else
matters like when we leave here and like
when we're just chilling on the couch
really at home it's just us and like and
and and we're doing this you know the
first thing Bradley said to me one of
the first things was like you don't
gotta be nothing but yourself I just be
real just be real he was like just be
real and um it's like what I'm like all
right I'm gonna be real you know I think
I think you know we're blessed to do
we're blessed to make art make films
write songs do things like that and it's
like I think people just want to connect
and they want to feel something honest
and an honesty is pretty tough because
you got to dig deep and sometimes we
don't want to dig deep because it
requires work it requires having to look
yourself in the mirror and and hurt a
little bit but man it's like after you
hurt you know that the pain the pace Ike
when you when you work out you
break the the muscle tissue only for it
to multiply so it's like you know you
just you get deep so you can rise above
and be like for me or for Ali for you
for me you know anytime someone told me
to you know get a nose job or work with
you know choreographer or dress like
this or be like that I always turned it
on its head and made it mine and it was
so important to me that my voice was
always inside of the art that I was
putting into the world because if like
you know like Jackson says to ally in
the movie like if you don't have
something to say you know there's no
there's no really worth in saying it at
all that that's what makes you an artist
is perspective and I really loved in his
filmmaking that that that was such an
essential theme of this movie
[Music]
one of the most powerful scenes for me
is when Jackson brings Ali on stage for
the first time and she has this moment
of realizing this is everything I've
always wanted and now life is never
going to be the same after this I call
it the Ali moment you know what was your
alley moment when you realized wow I'm
doing it but now tomorrow's not going to
be the same as yesterday I would think
of two things you know one would be the
first time I heard my first single on
the radio I was in Canada and I was in a
car and I started screaming and crying
but truthfully it was when I looked into
the eyes of my fans and I saw myself and
I knew that I had said something that
drew people like me towards me and
that's when things for me really changed
it's awesome Sam
what was your alley moment and what
point in your career did you say wow I'm
doing I'm doing this now and now my
life's gonna never be the same has been
too long for me to remember I think the
thing that I always go back to and have
often thought through the course of this
journey here is the sound of lucky I am
to still be added number one but to have
opportunities to work with the people I
work with and at the moment sunscreen
that I've had I've just been very very
fortunate a long way from Sacramento at
nine years old when I first decided this
is really what I wanted to do and just
feel blessed to have the opportunity and
still have an opportunity thanks to guys
like Bradley I personally think you're
doing some of the best stuff that you've
ever done before as an outdoor keep
doing it man thank you because it's good
you know
sure this all the way the music is gonna
be something I think audiences don't
forget from this film and I'm curious
for Bradley and Lady gaga when you're
crafting these songs what's influencing
you and what do you want people to feel
when you
writing them well I mean the the music
is an essential element it's a character
in the movie it's it it's not mutually
exclusive from the rest of the way this
whole process has evolved and I I
wouldn't do it any other way if we got
to do it again and we were making there
was an arsenal of songs by the time we
started filming but they were also songs
they were being written during filming
and that we're being parceled out and
put here in an element of it here
sometimes on the day and it's just and
that we were able to have that dexterity
because we all worked so hard she worked
so hard and so hard on the soundtrack
and we had people like Jason Isbell
who wrote maybe it's time which was
really the beginning of the discovery of
what Jackson could be as a musician Mark
Ronson and Lady gaga wrote shallow
together with another writer which was a
staple moment as you said in the movie
Lucas Nelson who it's late his plane was
late but he would be sitting with us he
is a he is the heart very much a part a
major artery of this film musically he
and his band promise for the real Hilary
Lindsey we just had this incredible
what do you call it it was a synergy and
we you know we were constantly working
in this studio and the script was being
worked on at the same time and you know
I remember even after we filmed the
scene in the cot bar I know I ran into
my Sprinter van and I started to write
this song I don't know what love is
which is the wedding song so you know
that was a new song that was birthed and
I remember for hardly texting me black
eyes the song that starts the movie you
know in the middle of the night he was
like I wrote this last night what do you
think of it and it was it was so
exciting for me to watch him become a
musician and I really think that it was
essential to this you know project and
such a testament to his humility and
generosity as a director is he accepted
me as an actress and I you know I
accepted him fully as a musician and we
did it all kind of at the same time and
we switched things up on the fly when we
needed to
and we kept things as for when when they
were like maybe it's down Olivia always
[Applause]
baby it's time to do
[Music]
dicks legs you know I feel like this
movie is very much about chasing the
dream and chasing what you love when you
chase what you love does love always get
in the way I think that the the obstacle
really is in the character of the music
you know Ali changes quite a bit and we
crafted Ali's sound in the beginning you
know out of Jackson's sound because I
worked with Lucas Nelson and his band
and with Bradley and then she starts to
shift and change and by the time we get
to the bathtub scene at the end of the
movie you know he's questioning her
about her lyrics and how she's changed
and and you know are you still do you
still have a point of view or he's still
saying what you really want to say and I
think that that's more of the challenge
that is brought into the love and also
the we want to make a human story so the
challenges are the past and your family
and sequence of events that have
occurred and the outside world and your
relationship to the outside world into
yourself I would actually say that the
thing that allows them to pursue their
dreams is their love you know she you
meet him in the beginning of the movie
the movie could be a short you know
because of where he is when you meet him
he's almost done she revitalizes him and
then same way with her she would have
just kept going they were they were just
slowly starting to go again away from
their dreams and that big I think the
fuel of their love actually is what at
least gave them the opportunity that the
small potential dream to fulfill it but
because of him primarily not being able
to to grow and to cultivate what had
happened in his life prior to being 43
it wasn't it was impossible but the
glove is the actual thing that that is
the means by which the story is told
there would be no movie if they didn't
have that low no if he believes in her
and and that helps her to believe in
herself right thank you so much for
making a spectacular job wish you all
the luck in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]